chuckle regarding mistakes what are some
of your own and some you've seen made by
leaders you've looked up to and how to
recover can someone ever fully regain
trust this is actually pretty easy one
because look if you make a mistake on it
the worst thing you can do if you make a
mistake is trying to avoid taking blame
for it that's the worst thing you can do
and if you think about the bosses that
you've had and you had some boss that
made a mistake and he's like Noah wasn't
my fault you just blew totally lose
respect for him so you can't do that you
got to take you got to take ownership of
it because again if you think about the
bosses that you've had and the times
that you had a boss that made excuses
you don't have any mercy on them you're
just ruthless on them mmm you just pick
them apart so that's step number one is
you know take ownership if you make a
mistake and that's how it's always
seemed to me from as I looked up the
chain of command you know if I saw a guy
that made mistakes and then he took
ownership of them like okay cool
the guy's you know he knows he made a
mistake cool will will support him if
they're doing the other thing and
they're blaming everybody else they're
not taking ownership you're gonna have a
hard time with it and as a matter of
fact I actually had a mutiny in in one
of my platoons where this is a long time
ago it's you know all the names are long
since forgotten but we had a we had a a
mutiny in our platoon where we said you
know pretty much us us lower enlisted
guys we had a we went to the we
literally went to the commanding officer
and said we don't work with this guy
yeah so you know all these ideas that
people have of the you know military and
of you know we obey orders and all this
stuff I mean think of what a little
jackass I was we you know we said well
you know what we don't want office guy
we're gonna go to the commanding officer
and tell him we don't want to work for
this guy
and a creating officer to his full
credit
he was like listen guys you can't have a
mutiny not at my command not on my team
you guys suck it up you figured out a
way to work it out
mmm go do what you're told get in line
oh the mutiny didn't work and then he
fired the guy yeah
and over he like basically made it
perfectly clear like this is your one
chance hmm and he fired him
dang but it was it was it was pretty
crazy to see to see it happen but and I
say this all the time it wasn't because
the guy lacked tactical scale it wasn't
because he wasn't physically fit it most
of the reason was because he just
couldn't take any ones you know advice
he wouldn't listen to anybody and so
when he was making a mistake it was no
no we'll do it this way no it's okay
constant cover-up for himself and
obviously it it didn't work out for him
so your mutiny sorta just put him on put
him on notice though this is right up
essentially yeah but I think the
commanding officer I think was really
just doing the right thing saying look
guys you can't have a mutiny doesn't
work that way this is the military get
back in there do what you're supposed to
do and then he was like okay I gotta
fire this guy must not be good to have
every enlisted guy in the platoon come
forward and say I don't want to work
with this guy yeah that's not a good
sign so the commanding officer did an
outstanding job and he was actually a
great great commanding officer to so and
it worked on the DL okay it worked on
the DL yes as echo would say and then I
actually the guy that took over was one
of the best guys I ever worked for if
not the best yeah it was pretty awesome
and then as far as regaining trust which
is the other part of the question this
almost as soon as you admit that you
made a mistake
you are automatically regaining trust
that's where you start you're gaining
trust yeah and it just goes from there
then you follow through with what you
say you know you're constantly trying to
build trust in relationships that's what
you're trying to do in the minute you're
lying to people how are you building
trust and if you make a mistake and you
say it's not your fault then that's a
lie and everyone knows it
yeah that that fear is
especially not especially but in regards
to regaining trust so to speak you know
when someone admits mistakes they have
that fear that oh they're gonna think I
don't know what I'm doing or I don't
have a handle on this you know so
doesn't matter it's so doesn't matter
it's so much better to go hey guys I
don't know how to do this
can you show me how to do this I'm not
sure I've never done this before or hey
never I've never used this kind of
weapon before can you give me an onion
doc on this thing the worst thing you
can do is step up to the line with a
weapon you've never used before not know
how to lock and load it or clear and
safe it'll look like a total idiot
because then you look like a guy that is
too arrogant and too insecure to ask
yeah it's actually it's actually a sign
of insecurity if you can't ask when you
need some help with something yeah and
it's funny how one Pete when people are
in that position and all kind of it just
this is kind of a general thing to know
is that you're you come off way more
transparent than you think
you know how people will like I don't
know something just as small as like
name-dropping if you named up someone
right even or you just mentioned this
person name but you're really
name-dropping even in a small way yeah
yeah like people can smell that yeah so
even like this stuff stuff that's a
little bit more important where if a
leader is insecure about something I
want to make like he knows everything
buddy really died when I do stuff like
that
I know but yeah I hate when I do stuff
like that yeah transparent everyone
everyone knows it and a lot of people
Brad they're not in touch with that they
think that oh yeah they don't know cuz
I'm just gonna sort of mention it and
there's all these little things that
it's just you just reek of yeah and I
don't I don't want to put it like that I
want I'll just say like I said you're
way more transparent than you think yeah
you know in transparent in this day and
age actually has a positive connotation
on if you know that yeah but people view
always really transparent guy you read
he really just tells you what's going on
if you're deliberately trying you're
using it in a negative way so I look
people can see right through year
exactly yes yes yeah yeah when you're
not trying to be transparent right
there's a big difference there and
totally true but it is definitely better
just to you know ask and say hey I don't
know that insecurity then when you don't
feel like asking something that's it'll
knock your knowing it says oh you're
insecure yeah what do you hey you know
what I don't how to do this can you can
you ban with us I am stuck on this
problem here can you can you give me
help with us cuz I don't how to do it
hmm
people don't say all this guys unless
you're doing it every three sentences
there's evidence you haven't studied
yeah yeah cuz you got a study you got to
know your trade gotta know your craft
and if you don't you gotta learn it yeah
oh you got to break out the books and
get on it but once you've broken out the
books and now there's a little bit of
stuff that you still don't understand
well guess what just ask the question
yeah cuz your frontline troopers are
gonna know more than you they shouldn't
know more than you yeah you know this
it's highly likely to they don't know
more than you I mean I was a radio man
for eight years and the SEAL Teams and
by the time I was a lieutenant commander
in a troop I didn't know as much as
those you know guys knew about all the
new radios and stuff so I just have to
ask a question it's no big deal
yeah if you're secure and your
leadership you're you're fine to ask a
couple questions it's not that big of a
deal yeah but you are not clear the lie
to people you're not clear to make
excuses and that's what that's how you
regain the trust is by telling people
the truth it's really a simple concept